ailleurs en ukraine à kharkhiv quatre
morts dans de nouveaux bombardements
cyril payen vous êtes notre envoyé
spécial les bombardements sont intenses
dans la ville
effectivement ils sont pas encore dans
la vie nous étions avec moi m farhad
justement dans les quartiers nord dans
les villages il y à un moment je vous
parle encore des tirs d'artillerie assez
violent il ya de la fumée juste dans ces
quartiers nord nous venons d'arriver
dans le le centre puisque évidemment il
ya une grande commotion dans la ville
puisque ça fait plus de 15 jours qu'il
n'y a pas eu de france yves sur kharkiv
ça a pris tout le monde par surprise il
ya un bilan effectivement vous le disiez
qu'il n'est pas définitif puisque pour
l'instant c'est qu'il ya quatre morts
des blessés mais surtout toute la ville
est de nouveau résolument en alerte on a
vu énormément de voitures militaires de
temps que de convoi qui partait vers
cette partie nord et nous avons été
fortement des comptes a été déconseillé
par don d'aller au delà des check points
du nord et d'ailleurs de le premier
check point de passer au second l'armée
nous a totalement barré la route il
était absolument devenu obligatoire de
faire demi tour vers le centre mais là
au moment où je vous parle on entend des
tirs qui sont effet un kilomètre de là
où je me trouve je me rappelle qu en
l'état car qu'est la seconde ville
d'ukraine qui a repoussé l'offensive
militaire russe il ya quinze jours et
qui avait été en fait qu'ils avaient
libéré en fait les alentours de kharkiv
donc tout cela vient comme une surprise
il est beaucoup trop tôt pour comprendre
la raison de cette nouvelle offensive
d'artillerie des russes alors que on
sait toutes les forces se concentrent à
150 km dont se trouve dans le donbass
l'az est une nouvelle option offensive
ce que je peux vous dire que c'est que
ça prend tout le monde ici par surprise
hélas pour les rares habitants qu'on
pouvait voir environ 100 bien un
mouvement de panique d'ailleurs il n'ya
autour de nous que des voitures de
militaires qui font qu'ils convergent
vers les checkpoints du nord donc voilà
la situation alors qu'il vient d'avoir
encore un tir qui ce qui a vient de
retentir non loin de là on se trouve
dans les quartiers nord de khar qu'yves
merci pour ces éléments cyril payen avec
mohamed farhat c'est derrière la caméra
envoyés spéciaux
à kharkhiv où donc les
russe semble se rapprocher merci avoue
cyril aussi